quentin était chez les soviets les
matriochkas étaient de vrais poupée il y
aura dix ans le 3 mars prochain
disparaissait hergé le père de tintin
qui reste aujourd'hui encore la star
mondiale numéro un de la bd le
personnage le plus admiré mais est aussi
le plus copié et le plus détournée dans
ce que l'on appelle désormais les albums
pirates parce qu'elle joue c'est bon et
maryse richard se sont lancés sur les
traces de ses fautes 1
cette version colorier de tintin au pays
des soviets n'existe pas enfin pas
officiellement de même pour cet album
dessiné et complétée du train mythique
tintin et l'alph art qu'hergé l'esa au
stade des skis c'est d'abord ça les
pirates des éditions clandestine
d'originaux plus ou moins transformé
deux versions intégrales directement
sorti on ne sait comment lui studios
hergé mais de l'interprétation au
détournement il n'y a qu'un pas que les
pirates du monde entier franchissent
allègrement de quoi ravir les
collectionneurs les aussi écorné le
mythe de leur jeunesse
il ya quand même des choses qui nous
manquait bon quand j'étais heureux de
voir donc une fois qu'ils font mal et
puis par moments aussi qu'ils le feront
un plaisir plus dur pour tati nos films
et surtout tata paris où on voit tatin
raciste misogyne il est vraiment
méprisable et c'est l'album qui seront
le plus dur après dans d'autres albums
pirates pour une autre action par
exemple une action politique
tintin sympathisants de l'ira gauchistes
aux militants anti nucléaire irradié
le moins que l'on puisse dire est que
les pirates se donne rarement dans la
dentelle
tintin sernam une guéguerre politicienne
française le héros là où fait se prête
particulièrement à ces détournements
parce qu'hormis de vieilles accusations
de racisme et d'antisémitisme primaire
tintin a toujours été politiquement lice
pourvoyeur les idées dominantes de son
temps je pense que si les rg étaient
toujours vivants il nous aurait
peut-être un tintin qui serait
écologistes maintenant pourquoi pas mais
le plus grand bonheur des pirates et de
données atteint pas les défauts dont il
est totalement dépourvu dans les très
fameux de tintin en suisse et tintin à
paris on découvre les parents terribles
du reporter un confrère qui a une
fâcheuse tendance à fumer n'importe quoi
boire plus que de raison et se jeter sur
toutes les filles qui passent parfois
même sur 1000 la vie sexuelle des
teintes un pirate est souvent est bridée
dans des face lift manquant diablement
de poésie et au sens artistique très
inégale c'est bien sûr pour cette raison
que bruno masure nous a formellement
interdit de les montrer je n'ai rien dit
du tout vrai ou faux tintin en tout cas
il ne faut pas tomber dans le panneau
transition tout à fait subtil